any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to another episode of
the into the impossible podcast special
edition think like a nobel prize winner
we are welcomed and blessing a one
blessed by the visit and appearance of
uh william bill phillips of nist in
geithersberg i believe it is uh maryland
and uh bill is a titanic intellect
influence and uh just an incredible
person he was introduced to me by my
friend muhammad nazri
abdullah from malaysia and he's also
friends of past guests on the show
including
jim gates up at
brown university but now making his way
back to maryland to be closer to bill
bill how are you doing today
great good to see you it's great to see
you too i just loved your talk uh uh
when i heard it and the malaysian
seminar that nasri had us both on we got
little swords from participating sent
through the mail that must have been fun
for the post office
but today we're going to talk about a
host of things related to your storied
career which resulted in in part in you
uh receiving along with stephen chu and
claude cohen
of the 1997 nobel prize in physics for
what i remember this is in my later part
of graduate school as one of the biggest
breakthroughs that i'd ever witnessed in
experimental physics which is the
creation of trapped cold atoms using
laser light
basically something that i thought would
be impossible but what did i know back
then and as you know the theme of this
podcast is you have to go into the
impossible so uh so currently uh bill is
a
as i said at nist and uh uh with his uh
with his team there including past guest
nicole younger halpern and other
collaborators he has uh devised really a
phenomenal pedagogical introduction to
some of the most exciting physics on
earth i study the cosmos so i'm a little
bit partial to these things that float
around in space but if you have to do
stuff on earth do it with a laser and if
you have to do something do it very
precisely and bill that's your hallmark
that's what you're known for so uh today
you're gonna present uh some slides and
i may interrupt but it's not rude don't
don't think it's rude bill points out
you know if you ever are part of a big
family you know that we interrupt and
we're all family and physicists and i'm
also going to be clicking on and off to
take questions from the audience that
was submitted earlier we'll do that at
the very end so i might interrupt i
might not and then at the end i might be
clicking around so don't get disturbed
bill are you okay with those rules
absolutely in fact i encourage uh
interruptions if if anything needs to be
clarified or expanded upon i'll very
much appreciate an interruption
wonderful the title of this
presentation is a new measure the
revolutionary quantum reform of the
metric system and as you heard i'm uh
part of nist's laser cooling and
trapping group uh gretchen campbell is
my group leader paulette trey porto ian
spielman i did singa charles clark and
most recently nicole younger halpern
who's been on this show
already
are the other permanent members of the
group with whom it's my pleasure to work
on a regular basis
i'm not only representing nist
the
national metrology institute of the
united states i'm also representing the
international union of peer and applied
physics
which has been a key player in the
um
the the development of the international
metric system and i've been spreading
the word about the latest reforms so
um what is this revolutionary uh reform
well first of all
science is about what you can measure at
least this is what uh
people like kelvin said
and in order to express the results of
measurements you need to have units
and as an international
scientific community
we have agreed to use the metric system
of units which is formally known as the
international system of units
because this was done in the 19th
century
when french was the international
language of diplomacy
it's the system international
and we abbreviate that as the s.i
and the metric system came into being
with the french revolution around the
end of the 18th century and what i'm
here to tell you is that just recently
on the 20th of may which is world
metrology day in 2019
we have experienced the greatest
revolution in measurement since the
french revolution
so what is the nature of that revolution
well the metric system the s.i
uh is based upon
what we call base units seven base units
all the other things we measure are some
combination of these other units uh the
kilogram for mass the meter for length
the second for time the ampere for
electric current the kelvin for
thermodynamic temperature
the mole for quantity of matter and the
candela for
luminous intensity so everything else uh
is some combination of these things so
like joules is going to be kilogram
meters squared per second squared uh
and uh that's another si unit
now the reform the nature of the reform
is that every one of these seven base
units
is now defined
by fixing the values of constants of
nature
now
in order to explain how this is even
possible i mean how do we get to fix a
value for a constant of nature doesn't
nature do that well in order to explain
how this works
and with apologies to the late great
stephen hawking i'm going to bring you
my version of a brief history of time
since uh
well
as long as
anybody has
has thought about it
seconds were a certain fraction of a day
i mean there's 24 hours in a day there's
60 minutes in an hour there's 60 seconds
uh in a minute so a second is one day
divided by 86
400. well that sounds great pretty clear
the trouble is that
at least since around 1900
we've known that the length of the day
changes
and this isn't just the kind of changes
that happen as the earth goes around the
sun
you can average that out and
use something called the mean solar day
but the fact of the matter is that
things like the tides exert a frictional
force on the rotation of the earth and
that slows the earth down
earthquakes can redistribute the mass of
the earth and that changes its moment of
inertia and because angular momentum is
conserved in the absence of
an external torque that's going to
change the rotation rate if ocean
currents change that will also change
the
angle momentum due to the water and so
the angle momentum due to everything
else has to compensate for that so
there's all sorts of reasons why
um the rotation rate of the earth isn't
constant and we've known that since 1900
we've actually had clocks that could see
that the rotation rate of the earth was
changing since around 1900
in the middle of the 20th century
a wonderful thing happened we started to
have atomic clocks this is a picture of
the very first atomic clock built at the
predecessor to my institution nist it
was then called the national bureau of
standards
well it wasn't exactly an atomic block
it was a molecular clock
the ammonia molecule was used to
be the ticker in this atomic clock
that was the first atomic clock ammonia
didn't quite catch on but a few years
later at the sister laboratory to nist
in uh
in the united kingdom of the national
physical laboratory uh they did
something that really did catch on the
first cesium cloth here's a picture of
that from
1955
uh there's an atomic beam of of caesium
going down this tube and what happens is
that
uh here's the cesium atom so just
imagine this easy man as being a nucleus
with a valence electron somewhere
outside
all the all the other inner electrons
and both the nucleus and the electron
are spinning which means they create a
magnetic field
and that means there's an energy
associated with the orientation
of this electron spin in the magnetic
field now in an oversimplified version
if that spin flips
and points in the other direction
there's going to be an energy difference
and that energy difference corresponds
to a frequency and we can induce
this spin to flip by shining in
microwaves at just the right frequency
so if i shine in microwaves at this
frequency that you can see right here a
little bit more than nine gigahertz then
this electron will flip its spin and
we'll be able to tell that but if the
frequency is wrong
then it won't flip its spin this is what
we call resonance you've got to have the
frequency of the microwaves frequency of
the light
match the natural frequency of the atom
in order to get it to change state
so when the atom changes its state after
we put in these microwaves we know that
the frequency was just right
remember this is an oversimplification
there's a lot more to it than that but
basically that means that if you
if you get this thing to change its
state then you know the frequency of the
microwaves is this number in other words
we have defined
this frequency in cesium to be this
number
and the reason to do that was to define
what we mean by a second so instead of
having the second being defined by the
rotation of the earth which isn't
constant it's now defined by
the difference in energy between two
energy levels in a cesium atom and as
far as we know that's always the same it
doesn't change with time doesn't change
with what cesium atom you've got it's
the same everywhere so this is great
this is just the kind of thing that we
want and this is the current definition
of the second in the modern metric
system that is the duration of 9 billion
192 million whatever periods of the
radiation that corresponds to that
transition and you tell that you
got your frequency on that transition by
seeing that you made the transition well
ever since
people started to make cesium clocks
these clocks have been improving here's
a a plot of how good the uncertainty in
these clocks as a function of time
ever since that first clock in 1955
and here's where the redefinition was
made in 1967 and it just kept getting
better
but it bottomed out around part in 10 of
the 14. now you might say part 10 to 14.
come on that's incredible and it is but
you know what
at the national institute of standards
and technology your national metrology
institute we are not
satisfied and what was the thing that
caused this um
to bottom out at a partner the 14th well
it's the fact that the cesium atoms are
moving so fast if you heat up a lump of
caesium metal which is what we do
until it vaporizes and makes atoms
because that's what we want we want
isolated cesium atoms
they're moving over 100 meters per
second
and it's just hard to measure stuff
that's moving that fast
so in order to fix this problem
we used this technique called laser
cooling that brian alluded to
during his introduction now this is what
the laser cooling group is actually
known for that's why we're called the
laser cooling and trapping group
is because that's what we've been
developing over these years
and it allowed us to make these clocks a
whole lot better well i should say it
allowed other people to use the
techniques that we developed in the
laser cooling and trapping group to make
better clocks and today
these cesium clocks are good to a few
parts in 10 of the 16. so here's the
rest of that curve and now these things
are bottoming out at a few parts in 10
of the 16. are there uncertainties on
the uncertainty bill or are they just
smaller than the dot size
yeah no you
yeah there are certainly uncertainties
on on the uncertainties i don't remember
exactly what they are but you would uh i
would say that the uncertainty on the
cesium clock is is about 2 times 10 to
the minus 16 and the uncertainty on that
uncertainty is probably about a half
of of apart and 10 to the 16. you know
it's really
hard to estimate these uncertainties at
these incredible levels and even harder
estimate the uncertainty yeah right and
then is the um
is
cesium kind of grandfathered in
something that make a good choice
yes yes exactly so back in 1955
it was a good choice for a couple of
reasons
it's got the largest hyperfine frequency
of any alkali metal
because it's the heaviest
and you want a large frequency because
if there's anything that messes you up
that's approximately constant like say a
straight magnetic field it'll be a
smaller fraction
so this is really good you want a high
frequency
um it's being so heavy
uh means that at a given temperature the
atoms are going more slowly because
temperature is just a measure of kinetic
energy kinetic energy is one half mv
squared so if m is bigger v is going to
be smaller for the same energy
and it's got a pretty high vapor
pressure at room temperature so you
don't have to heat it up much so all
these things are
are in its favor another thing that was
really important in 1955 that's not so
important today is that cesium atoms are
easy to detect they've got a very low
ionization potential that is it doesn't
take much energy to pull the electron
off
so if one of these atoms um sits down on
a metal surface like tungsten that has
what we call a high work function that's
the amount of energy it takes to pull an
electron out of the tungsten
the electron would rather be in the
tungsten
than on the atom so that the electron
gets sucked into
the metal leaving an ion and that ion is
easy to detect
so that was really important in 1955 not
so important today because we just shine
a laser on the cesium atom we get a
burst of photons and it's easy to detect
that way
and it turns out that cesium is one of
the best atoms for laser cooling so it
has turned out to be a pretty good
choice
not perfect because it's got bad
collisional properties which is one of
the reasons why it bottoms out at about
uh part 10 of the 16 uh but
we're going to do better
okay okay so here's a picture of one of
those cesium clocks don mikov and steve
jeffords cool those cesium atoms down to
less than one millionth of a degree
above absolute zero at that temperature
these cesium atoms are moving not at uh
over 100 meters per second but at less
than one centimeter per second
they launch them up in a vacuum tube
about a meter high they fall back down
after about a second and instead of
having milliseconds to measure they've
now got a whole second to measure things
and this produces these incredible
clocks that are good to a few parts in
10 of the 16. these are fountains
fountain atomic foundry this is what's
called a fountain clock because you're
throwing the atoms up and they fall back
down sort of like one of these vertical
jets of water that you see in a little
pond or a big lake there's one in lake
geneva right las vegas has a couple of
them yeah
and
so out of you know sort of recalling the
the beauty of those of those fountains
we call this an atomic foul okay
so now
so so here's a very important thing we
started with something that
was basically an artifact
the earth i mean there's nothing special
about the earth
uh and it changes
uh and we've changed to the property of
an atom something that as far as we know
doesn't change
and something that depends on quantum
mechanics and this is a key concept
about what we want to do
with
the um
uh
uh
the definition of units we want to get
away from things that are arbitrary and
go toward things that are fixed by
nature and so you see we defined what
the frequency of this transition in the
cesium atom is
and that was the first one of our
uh of our our units the second that was
uh
defined in this in this way by well it's
not quite true but
okay i told a little hi there we'll go
back come back to that later
let's say it was the first one of the
units defined by defining a constant of
nature and you see how much better this
is
uh
this is is always going to be good the
the atom's not going to change okay
um
now an even better story
short history of length
now uh time historically was pretty
important but length was really
important because it had to do with
commerce and construction if you're
selling people things
by the the yard then you've got to know
what a yard is and the early approach
was to use the human body you know a
merchant would
measure out a yard of fabric uh based on
the length of his arm
uh you know a foot was a foot a cubit
was the distance between the elbow and
the end of the uh
uh
the end of the hand uh a fathom is the
uh
is the the arm spread um
uh now this was great because you always
had your unit right with you the trouble
is it wasn't very consistent so if
you're buying fabric from a short
merchant you might not be getting what
you want
so one approach that ancient people took
was they used the uh uh the body of one
particular person
typically the monarch
okay so in ancient egypt the um
royal cubit was based upon the length of
the pharaoh's forearm
and this is what they used to build the
pyramids uh but of course the pharaoh
wasn't always around
when you're out in the field building
something
and uh so what they did was they made an
artifact
they made a rod of stone
that was the length of the pharaoh's
forearm
and that was the representation an
artifact
of the royal cubit now the people out in
the field making actual measurements
used a wooden standard
that was calibrated against the stone
standard every month
and the penalty for not calibrating
every month was the death penalty these
guys were really serious about that's
worse than losing tenure
exactly
slightly
but but you know this series is about
metrology resulted in really good good
results the baselines of the pyramids
are good to consistent to a fraction
small fraction of a percent they're
square to 12 arc seconds these are
well-made
uh buildings and and they're well made
because of the fact that they were
serious about metrology
and this idea of having an artifact
um
was extremely widespread throughout the
world in medieval europe
there were artifacts often uh cemented
into the wall in the town square here's
a town in germany in regansburg and
that's a fathom and you can see by
comparison to an american tourist it's a
big fathom
so this is probably a great place to be
buying uh fabric
if you were to go
into the surrounding area
it wouldn't be the same now this is a
really vexing problem but incredibly
common
at the time of the french revolution
it was said that there were something
like a hundred thousand different
measurement units throughout europe
maybe just throughout france and the
revolutionaries figured we are going to
fix this
we are going to have a unit of measure
that gets away from all this variability
based on artifacts
so what did they do they chose the earth
as the standard of length they defined a
new standard of length called the meter
and the meter was 1 10 millionth of the
distance between the pole and the
equator and the idea was well the earth
belongs to everybody so this is a kind
of a democratic definition and just to
be sure that it's completely universal
it's the it's the meridian that goes
through paris yes
so in order to figure out what a meter
was
they sent out two teams of surveyors
these were top-notch astronomers in fact
because they had to know where they were
in in latitude and in longitude and they
measured the um
the paris not the paris but the dunkirk
to barcelona
uh meridian starting from paris one team
going north one team going south and
when they came back
they knew what the meter was in terms of
the old units the asean regime
and they really
had done
what what was hoped for they had
something that was good for all times
and for all people this is a medal that
was cast to commemorate this idea you
see this mythological creature measuring
the earth and that is in fact what they
did they measured the earth trouble is
it's not so easy to check
and so they made an artifact
and this artifact uh platinum rod is the
meter of the archives in 1799 this thing
was made and deposited in the archives
of france reflecting this
measurement of the earth that had been
done by
these
uh french scientists
and this became the standard of length
for
all of france
a few decades later
1875
countries of the world got together and
decided to adopt the metric system
uh as their own system of units
and decided they would make a new
version of the meter and they made a rod
you see pictured here where the distance
between two scratches on it was equal to
the end to end distance of the
uh the meter of the archives
uh 1875
well that's when the treaty was made was
in the 1880s that they finally made this
meter
1880s in france
the physicists in france and in other
parts of the world had spent this
century learning among other things that
light was a wave
and one of the things you can do with
waves is you can interfere them and you
can make devices here's a cartoon
picture of a michelson interferometer
and michelson was the first one to
measure
the length of a meter in terms of a
wavelength of light
and the idea is that you bring some
light in it goes on to a beam splitter
like a half silvered mirror
some of it's reflected over here so if
it's transmitted both of these beams are
reflected back to the beam splitter and
combined
and they combine to perform to create
this interferogram so where the waves
are in opposition to each other you have
destructive interference and you get
darkness and where the waves are aligned
with each other you get constructive
interference and you get something light
if you move this mirror by a quarter of
a wavelength which is a couple hundred
nanometers
then this thing changes from light to
dark so it's really easy to measure
something to measure lengths at the
nanometer scale
you're comparing that to a meter bar
that's got two scratches on it those
scratches are 10 or 20 microns wide and
you've got to determine where the center
of that thing is with a microscope that
has an optical resolution of one micron
so it didn't take long before people
decided this was the way to measure
length
but it took until 1960 that they
redefined
what we meant by a meter in 1960 they
which was the year the laser was
invented they uh defined the light from
this uh
lamp you see just this lamp that has
krypton gas in it when you run an
electric discharge in it it makes an
orange light and the uh wavelength of
that orange light was used to define
what we mean by a meter
now
that was the laser was invented it
didn't take long before people made
lasers
the light from which was even more pure
than the light that was coming from uh
this lamp
so here is a picture of one of those
lasers this is called a
an iodine stabilized helium neon laser
the gas inside the laser cavity between
two mirrors
is a mixture of helium and neon
and then it's locked to a transition in
molecular ionine and everybody used this
as their de facto standard of length
um
by 1983 people had decided we have to
redefine
the meter because it's defined in terms
of this this crummy
now crummy uh krypton lamp compared to
this beautiful laser so we ought to
redefine the meter now the obvious thing
to do would have been to define the
meter in terms of the wavelength of the
iodine stabilized healing helium
nanolaser there it is
everybody using it why not make that the
new definition
fortunately they did not make the
obvious choice
instead they made
a brilliant choice
they defined the speed of light
right why does that work because of this
universal relationship the wavelength of
light times its frequency is equal to
the speed of light regardless of what
the wavelength is
and by 1983 people had learned how to
measure the frequency of light so that
meant this worked if we measured the
frequency
and define the speed of light we
immediately know what the wavelength is
and we've got
a new meter stick that's always going to
be the same because this unit this
relationship is universal is that the
factor
then referring the meter to the second
because you measure frequency in inverse
seconds exactly but the second is so
good remember part in 10 to 16 well
maybe not in 1983 but
still pretty good yeah it was orders of
magnitude better than what you could
measure length to
so
the second you're absolutely right you
need it but it's so wonderful that we
don't have to worry about it but it's
part of the definition so you needed to
define the second before you could
define the meter
so once we know what a second is then we
say that the meter is the distance the
light travels in this fraction of a
second and basically you see what that
does is it defines the speed of light to
be this number
in meters per second and i don't think
it could have actually according to you
know sociologists who study this i don't
think it could have been done earlier
than 1980 you know so it's kind of
fortuitous that these things came about
because as you know there was a
persistent you know kind of confirmation
bias effect with measurements of the
speed of light that they were all kind
of tracking and then they stabilized and
then there was this big shift down and
but so and that didn't really occur
until the 1960s or 70s so if they had
done the obvious choices you said they
would have been wrong right yeah and and
the um well you know people say isn't it
too bad that we didn't define the speed
of light to be
300
right
well that would have been great but it
was too
late right
it's like it wouldn't be great if pi
really was three yeah well unfortunately
with pi we don't have the choice with c
we do have a choice but by the time the
decision was made a change that big in
the meter would have made everything
that had to fit together not fit
you know cylinders wouldn't fit in
pistons and it just would have been a
disaster
so um
too bad that would be great if if the
speed of light was exactly 300 million
uh meters per second but it wasn't to be
uh if only it had happened earlier if
only manufacturing hadn't developed such
precision
uh we could have we could have done
better but that's the way it was so but
anyway but but look at this
the great thing about this is that if
somebody makes a better laser
it's more stable and they did
somebody devises a new way of measuring
the frequency and they did
these the guys who did it jan hall and
ted hedge
made better lasers and devised ways of
measuring the frequency better it's
already incorporated into the definition
you don't need a definition because
somebody improved the technology by some
huge amount these guys did improve the
technology by some huge amount and
the definition had no need to change so
here's what happened we went from an
artifact to
a an atomic constant in krypton
and then to a fundamental constant of
nature this is really beautiful and with
this kind of definition
you don't ever need to change
you get a better atom and you can lock
your laser to that atom better than
before it's all good
and uh and and this is what i call the
beautiful definition
so
the meter has a beautiful definition
and on the 20th of may 2019
we brought this same beauty
to the definition of the kilogram the
ampere the kelvin and the mole
so why was that important to do and how
did we do it well
to understand that
uh i want to give you a life history of
mass
so
just like everything else there were
artifacts here's some polished stones
from ancient babylon one of these things
is called a shekel and
this was the weight for the babylonian
empire but if you were to go someplace
else
then
they're going to have a different set of
of weights uh and so the french
revolutionaries figured we're going to
fix this too
and we're going to use this same
approach where we
make it universal so they're going to
base their new
unit of mass called a kilogram
on the meter
the new unit of mass is equal to the
mass of
a cube of water
that is a tenth of a meter on the side
we call this a liter
okay so the mass of a liter of water is
defined to be a kilogram
great universal water is readily
available
but
just like everything else there's
problems
density of water changes with the
temperature
the
uh water it's hard to get exactly
a liter because water sticks to some
surfaces that it's wetset you know it
doesn't wet other kinds of surfaces you
get a little bit of changes in the
volume because of that and so guess what
they made an artifact
they made a piece of platinum and there
it is
holding it
that's the kilogram of the archives
right there look how tiny it is yeah
that's a kilogram of platinum platinum
was chosen because it's the densest or
one of the densest of all the materials
that we have which means that the
buoyance of the air doesn't affect it
very much you see when you're trying to
weigh something against something else
if the things have different densities
then you've got to account for
the buoyancy of the air
so you use the densest thing you can
well anyway that thing was made to be as
close as you could
make it to
uh the the the mass of a of a liter of
water
and that thing was deposited in the
archives in 1799 and became the the
standard of mass for france and then
decades later when the countries of the
world got together in 1875
to agree to adopt the metric system they
decided to make another
kilogram
made as closely as possible in fact they
made a whole bundle and they picked the
one that was as close to
the kilogram of the archives
as
as they could measure and that became
the international prototype of the
kilogram it's there under three glass
domes
and this is the last artifact
now think about this in the 21st century
so before 2019
in the 21st century the unit of mass
is still
this artifact a piece of metal that was
made in the 19th century that was based
on an object made in the 18th century
this is scandalous
but in the 21st century we are using
18th century technology to measure mass
if someone leaves a fingerprint on the
international prototype of the kilogram
all of us will lose weight
i always point out to my friends that
work at nist one of my students worked
on the definition of the vault
at nest in boulder and i always said
it's very important
because actually one of the most
egregious laws in the old testament
is from leviticus 19 which you probably
know but maybe not all of my listeners
know you shall not do unrighteousness in
judgment in length in weight or in
measure
and actually the punishment for that
bill you might know this but many people
was worse than the punishment for uh
obligatory like for for theft or
something like that it was it was
considered almost as egregious as
possible because an ordinary person is
capable of determining if somebody's
lying or cheating on them but they
couldn't tell if you were cheating about
weight or measure and so being dishonest
was actually a crime against god so you
are doing god's work literally in the
work that you guys do over there so i
want to thank you
do you think we should bring back the
death penalty for people with proper
weights and measures
well maybe just
fraud in general
we'll leave that
yeah all right another podcast yeah
that's right now interestingly there's
things about honest weights in magna
carta as well so this is something that
that people have really cared about for
a long time
well anyway nobody leaves a fingerprint
on the international prototype of the
kilogram but it appears that the mass is
changing nevertheless this is a plot
of in micrograms of how the other
kilograms that were made at the same
time
have changed relative to
the
uh international prototype telegram and
you'll notice that they're almost all
going in the same direction
this makes you think that maybe
it's the prototype kilogram that's
changing right well actually it seems
like everything is changing because none
of them are you know agreeing
um and uh the trouble is of course the
mass the international prototype
kilogram cannot change because by
definition it's a kilogram right
but that's intolerable
this was just like the old thing with
the second the the length of the second
was changing but it can't because it's
the definition of the second was based
on the mean solar day well that's just
intolerable so we have to
redefine what we mean by a kilogram
and what we want to do is to use this
same beautiful definition
uh
where by we defined uh the meter by
defining the speed of light so we want
to pick a constant of nature a
fundamental constant of nature
to define the kilogram well what
constant is that going to be well in
order to
tell you that let me remind you of what
i'm sure is the most famous equation in
all of history
equals mc squared what does this mean it
means that the ob the energy of an
object at rest
is equal to its rest mass times the
square of the speed of light
uh now there's another equation not
quite as famous but one i like very much
and that says the energy of a photon is
equal to its frequency
photon is just a particle of light so
the frequency of the light times
planck's constant and you could say what
is planck's constant well it's the
constant makes this true and
the thing that's important about this is
that it's the same for all frequencies
okay
uh so what does it mean the energy of a
photon a particle of light is equal to
planck's constant times the frequency of
the light now let's take these two
equations
set them equal to each other since
they're both equations for energy solve
for the mass
and it says that the mass now what does
that mean the mass what it means is
let's say i have some particle a nucleus
it emits a photon a gamma ray and i can
measure the frequency of that gamma ray
if i measure that frequency
and if i already know what the speed of
light is because we defined it back in
1983
and if today i define planck's constant
then i know
in kilograms how much the mass of that
nucleus changed
in a sense what i've done is i've
weighed a photon
now this is really just to illustrate
what we could do we don't we don't weigh
photons actually we could and we do just
not well enough
this guy this hero brian kibble
came up with a way an electro mechanical
device that we now know as a kibble
balance and i'm going to show you how
this works in a little cartoon movie so
here we go
so first of all i want to invite you to
think about the old way the traditional
way of measuring mass let's say we got
an unknown mass on this side of the
balance we put known masses on the other
side of the balance until the balance
balances so we keep adding mass on the
other side of the balance until it
balances and then we know
what the mass is of the unknown mass
we've done this you know
probably most of you have done this
uh in a lab sometime to measure the mass
or something that's the standard way of
doing it
now i want to invite you to think about
a different way of doing this imagine
that i
instead of standard known masses i put a
coil of wire on the other side
and i
put current in that coil wire and i put
it in a magnetic field let's say i've
got some permanent magnets here
if i know what the current is in that
coil
and if i know what the strength of the
magnetic field is and if i know what
direction the magnetic field is pointing
because you know you get the biggest
force when the magnetic field is
pointing at right angles to the current
and otherwise you got a cosine factor or
something or a sine factor okay so so
you have to know all that stuff if i
knew all of that stuff
then i would be able to calculate what
the force
is
that is being generated here because i
just you know
know it from maxwell's equations
and then if i measure the acceleration
of gravity i can figure out what this
mass is because i'm just comparing the
electromagnetic force to the
gravitational force now the trouble is i
can't do all those things i said that i
want to do i can't measure the magnetic
field well enough i don't know what
direction it's pointing i don't even
know where the current is going in this
wire
i know i can measure the current really
well
but all these other things are really
hard to do so here's where kibble comes
in
kibble says okay that's great let's do
another experiment with the same
apparatus
let's take that coil
let's open up the leads on that coil
and the coil is going to be in the same
magnetic field let's take the leads from
that thing and connect it to a voltmeter
and now move the coil
in the field of the magnet this is what
a generator does you move a current
carrying wire
in
well it doesn't have to carry current i
mean it'll the current will be generated
by the by the generator moving in a
magnetic field it generates current what
we're going to do is measure the voltage
that is generated we're not going to let
current flow we're going to measure the
voltage
and we're also going to measure the
velocity at which the coil is moving
that's why we call this the velocity
mode okay we measure the velocity that
it moves at and we can do that very well
we measure the voltage generated and we
can do that very well
and then we also
have this measurement from the other
part of the uh of the experiment what's
what we call the weighing mode
uh so we do this velocity mode measure
the velocity and the uh
and the voltage and then we put the
current in and we do this weighing mode
we we see how much current is required
to balance out the uh
the mass but we don't worry about making
all these other measurements because
that other one the velocity mode gave us
all the important stuff
here's why
the mass of the object times gravity is
that's the force being generated in the
weighing mode you multiply that by the
velocity from the velocity mode you've
got force times velocity
that's mechanical power
take the current from the weighing mode
multiply that by the voltage from the
velocity mode current times voltage is
electrical power
those two things have to be the same in
a proper set of units
so that means we can take this equation
that makes mechanical power equal to
electrical power
solve for the mass
and now we know the mass is equal the
current times voltage divided by the
acceleration of gravity times the
velocity
so that's our new way of measuring mass
but wait a minute you say you're trying
to cheat me
because you promised this was going to
have to do with planck's constant
and the reason why this has to do with
planck's constant is because of the way
in which we measure current and the way
in which we measure voltage
these
people
brian josephson and klaus von klitzing
figured out how to do voltage using
fundamental constants the joseph effect
gives you a
a voltage across
what's called a joseph's injunction two
superconductors separated by an
insulator the voltage across that
junction
depends upon the frequency that is
generated when you put that voltage you
get a frequency generated and
the ratio of the frequency to the
voltage is two e over h the charge of
the electron divided by plane's constant
clause function found that a resistance
kind of a funny resistance where you put
current in one direction you measure the
voltage in the other direction the ratio
of those two things is a resistance
is equal to
a sub integer multiple of h over e
squared and when you put all those
things into
these equations you find out that the
mass is proportional to h just like i
promised of course i went through that
kind of quickly but you know maybe we
can go over it later
i just had one one comment
when i did uh in my freshman year
sophomore year at case western reserve
as an undergrad
i did a uh the cavendish experiment uh
attempting to measure the gravitational
uh attraction of two spheres uh
basically and i remember getting uh you
know the right uh i got the right you
know prefactor an exponent
but my values for the prime factor was
the exponent it was like 11 times 10 to
the minus 6 or so instead of 6 times 10
to the minus 1 so it was all off but i
remember consulting myself with the fact
that capital g which goes into lower
case g absolutely is still the poorest
known fundamental
that's right yeah so how does it not get
limited by that yeah well because we
don't need to know what big g is
we can measure little g by dropping a a
a mirror
and you make what one of the mirrors
part of a an interferometer by the way
case western this is where michael said
did some of his great work that's right
michaelson morley
yep yeah and the michael's morning
experiment was which was a uh michaelson
interferometer well make one of the arms
of that michaelson interferometer a
falling mirror and you can count off the
fringes as a function of time and
measure the acceleration of gravity you
can do even better
by replacing that mirror with falling
atoms
and measuring the doppler shift of the
atoms as they fall and you can measure
gravity to better than you need to wow
okay not a lot better than you need to
but you know we're working on improving
that as well
so so that is done right in place and
here is a picture of one of those kibble
balances uh at nist and we realized the
kilogram to about a part 10 of the
eighth which is better than the dirt
effects that we were seeing over time in
that plot of
of mass differences versus time and
these guys are serious about metrology
they tattooed the values of fundamental
constants onto their forearms these are
like those ancient egyptians these
people are really are really uh serious
about
metrology how are we doing on time here
we got
well okay let me just just blow through
this very quickly yeah
using the same idea planck's constant
but a completely different approach
using
atoms and how fast they recoil when you
hit them with a photon
you can then measure the mass of an atom
in kilograms
compare the mass of that atom which you
hit with with photons and measure the
recoil to the mass of silicon atoms
make a perfect crystal of silicon
turn it into a near perfect sphere the
most perfectly spherical object ever
made on the face of the earth
measure its size measure the spacing of
the atoms in that perfect crystal if you
know what the spacing is and you know
how big the object is you know how many
atoms are there and since you know the
mass in kilogram of one atom you know
the mass in kilograms of this thing
and this gives you another way of using
planck's constant to get
uh a kilogram wow and all over the world
people have been doing this so here's
dots for where they've done the kibble
balance and for where they've done the
uh the silicon sphere and when they all
agreed to a sufficiently
uh
precise level that had been set by
international
committees
then
the change was made and here is a movie
that was shown
uh at versailles when 60 countries in
the world voted unanimously
to change the definition
it took more than 140 years
groundbreaking science and the agreement
from the world's scientific community
at times it seemed impossible accurate
precise measurements anytime anywhere
thanks
is
[Music]
so we finally did
what the
uh the french revolutionaries
uh
had set out to do was to make something
that was good for all time for all
people no more artifacts
uh and for me the idea that 60 countries
would unanimously agree to something it
it's the way things ought to be yeah
it's the way we should do things
internationally well there's a final
part of the story the ampere which used
to be the current that produced a
certain amount of force is now a certain
number of electrons per second because
we've defined the charge of the electron
and uh this means that e over h and 2
over h are defined quantities so the
metrology of voltage and current is now
based on these fundamental constants
the mole that used to be the number of
entities in 12 grams of carbon 12 is now
just a number
avogadro's number is now defined
the kelvin used to be 1 over 273.16
of the triple point of water
we now have a defined value of the
boltzmann constant and i love this
definition because it gets at the idea
of the microscopic
kinetic energy
of things that have a temperature
because
kt
is a measure of the
the um
kinetic energy of a single entity like a
single atom in a gas
is going to have that energy of of kt so
it brings the idea of temperature down
to this
atomic uh
quantum level so i really love this
definition so
the french revolution brought us the
metric system
length and kilogram
uh as as new
units of i mean meters and kilograms is
new units of length and mass
the
1875 cavalson dimetro brought us an
international agreement that we would
all adopt the metric system
uh
and now
uh on the 20th of may
which is the anniversary of the signing
of that 1875
treaty of the meteor we now have the
biggest revolution since the french
revolution all the base units are
defined by fixing values of the
fundamental constants and we really have
done what those french revolutionaries
wanted to do
something good for all time for all
people
except
except it seems for time itself because
time is still defined in terms of a
particular atom the cesium atoms and the
fact is we got better atoms now
and
we're going to have to redefine
the second
in taking advantage of these better
atoms which are operating at higher
frequencies remember i said
cesium one of the reasons was because
the frequency is higher well we're going
to go to frequencies that are orders of
magnitude higher optical frequencies
instead of 10 to the 10 10 to the 15
cycles per second
and
this is going to lead to
frequency standards that are just going
to keep getting better and better
they're already operating at parts in 10
of the 18
and no reason why they're not going to
work at parts and 10 of the 20th or even
better so
this is still yet to be done
the future of time well only time will
tell
thank you bill that was phenomenal that
was so wonderful and i've got uh a lot
of questions here so maybe you'll um you
want to stop your screen share so we can
see your full size
and i'm going to yes so
i said i wouldn't make any dad jokes
this week it's recording this before
father's day but i can't resist you know
so what do you call 10 to the 23rd uh
you know uh avocados do you know
oh actually actually it's it's uh uh
another definition of that do you know w
murder
stanford no i don't know him personally
but you heard the name right well uh in
his lab they're typically working with a
single molecule
so uh
this is uh
a mole divided by avocados numbers so
it's a guacamole
so so he's he's used that joke but the
other way around yeah exactly if a
single a single
a single molecule is a guacamole
substance
well bill you probably know are one of
the founders of experimental science
galileo galilei there's a pic there's a
finger puppet i keep him around
he said measure what's measurable and
make measurable what is not already so i
want to ask you what will we get from
optical lattice clocks and all the
things that we'll maybe talk about in a
part two someday i mean aren't isn't 10
to the you know minus 19 good enough
when do you why not stop there
and the answer is
not for the national institute of
standards and technology it's not why
why do we care well
one of the things that i'm really
excited about is
that
using these clocks we can test
whether the fundamental constants are in
fact constant
so one of the
the really important constants is the
fine structure constant now why is this
important it tells us in a dimensionless
way so in other words it doesn't depend
upon the arbitrary choices we've made
for what a meter and a second are it's a
dimensionless number it'll be the same
in every system of humans
it tells us how strong the
electromagnetic forces are and since
almost everything that we encounter in
daily life that doesn't have to do with
gravity
depends upon electromagnetic forces all
of chemistry you know the fact that
we're alive
depends upon electromagnetic forces
the fine structure constant is really
important to determine what life is like
and the question is is it the same from
year to year
well
if you have two atomic clocks
and they're operating on different atoms
where the transition frequency in those
atoms is dependent upon the fine
structure constant in different ways
looking at the ratio of those two clocks
will tell you
whether the fine structure constant is
changing and they've been doing those
experiments and we now know the defined
structure constant does not change to
something on the order of apart and 10
to the 18th per year
and
as we make these clocks better we will
be able to nail that down even better
but wait there's
more einstein's theory of general
relativity tells us
that two clocks
that are transported into different
places
different gravitational potentials uh
you know different uh accelerating
fields whatever
those two clocks will maintain the same
ratio
regardless of what we do to them so if
i've got two clocks that are up in a
satellite and i got
two similar clocks let's say one of them
is strontium and one of them is
ytterbium and i got a strontium and a
terpene clock up in the space station
uh and i got astronomy and terpene clock
in the lab in boulder and i measure
those ratios in both places
if they're not the same then it means
that einstein's theory is his
equivalence principle is wrong right
now
something's got to be wrong about
something because right now
quantum mechanics and general relativity
cannot be put together in a consistent
way
something's going to have to change
about one or both of them a lot of
people think it's the equivalence
principle
god forbid but the equivalence principle
is a wonderful principle but if it's not
right then maybe there's a route to
getting um
a gravity consistent with quantum
mechanics amazing
and
so if we can find out that it's not
right that it doesn't hold that'll be
fantastic so these are some of the
reasons why we want to make these clocks
better yeah
i have a video on uh optical lattice
clocks and juninese group
coming up so that'll be i'll link to it
somewhere up above um so now i want to
take just
but let me let me just say another thing
juni
we can't forget about anna maria ray yes
he's the theory muscle
behind these optical lattice clocks
yeah yeah and that got brought together
yeah just an unbeatable team well maybe
you'll introduce me to vote i think i
was in a competition once with juni uh
at uh to celebrate uh your hero and my
hero charlie townsend's 90th birthday
you were probably there right at
berkeley maybe in 19 in 2005 yeah that's
competition junie adam reece and me and
it was supposed to be you know or many
other people but they we came in the top
three i came in number one adam reese
came in uh you're you're near your
neighbor there he came in third uh and
on the day he won the nobel prize my old
older brother called me up and said well
you won that battle but he won the war
i'm still wait although you know with my
books uh you know called losing the
nobel prize i don't think it's going to
happen but and i do want to talk about
the nobel prize briefly i know you're on
a tight time schedule i'm so grateful
that you're here at all sharing your
your incredibly valuable time we have
some questions from the audience and
just a reminder uh audience questions
can be submitted on my youtube channel
dr brian keating or twitter dr brian
keating instagram same as well so the
first one is actually appropriate uh for
this weekend again another dad joke uh
so we know about your experience
trapping atoms have you ever trapped an
eve
here's another one this one is a famous
one you know you should never trust
atoms right right because they make up
everything good job but there is a
serious question from my listener uh
what is the material inside an atom
that's not stuff that's not quarks
that's not electrons is there anything
in there is it vacuum and void as
lucretius told us 2 300 years ago
yeah well this this goes to some really
really cool ideas which you
i i think know better than i
so so i mean all of us have this picture
of an atom with a nucleus and uh
electrons
i mean the typical pictures the
electrons are going out going around the
outside they're not really they're in a
cloud they're sort of everywhere at the
same time by the way why do they always
show lithium it always has three
electrons like lithium gets unfair
attention it's not lithium it's just an
iconic atom it's uh because if it were
lithium you wouldn't be able to have
three uh electrons in the same orbital
right it's true
it's it's just the most most visually
pleasing atom
interestingly with a sort of a bore
somerfeld picture right which is so
wrong
and yet so powerful
that we still keep it in our mind right
and boar won the nobel prize for that
right exactly and i mean it's really
interesting how wrong that picture is of
how useful and important it is
nevertheless right someone
has it
that i communicate with from time to
time has a tagline i forget who it's who
said it a model
is a lie
that helps you see the truth right
someone said all models are wrong but
some are more useful than others or
something like that yeah yeah well
anyway okay so
so electrons are fundamental particles
and uh they have a certain mass and we
now understand that they get their mass
uh from uh the higgs field and you know
the you've probably all read about the
the discovery of the higgs boson which
uh was predicted
as being something that would come along
with this higgs field that gives things
massive because it was there's a
question where does mass come from i
mean it sounds like a stupid question
because things just have mass but you
know
why do things have mass well i mean i
don't even understand it very well
but um because i'm just an
experimentalist right but but now we got
these things in the nucleus where most
of the mass is
those nucleons are not elementary
particles
they're made up of each one of the
nucleons protons or neutrons are made up
of three quarks the quarks are
elementary particles
now the mass of the nucleus is
not
equal to the sum of the masses the
quarks because there's a binding energy
and
it works the wrong way
usually
something that's tightly bound is gonna
have
a
uh a lower
mass than the sum of the other masses
because
you know it takes energy to pull them
apart but because the weird way in which
the the forces between nucleons work it
works the other way
most of the mass of the nucleus is
binding energy it's weird binding energy
and it doesn't come from the higgs
mechanism it comes from the binding part
so i don't know if that answers the
question no i think it does yeah but no
that's weird yeah it is weird
and even weirder bose einstein comments
it so john albert's one of my listeners
asked the question um effectively i'm
going to translate it into he's asking
about you know is it a fifth phase of
matter what i what i've wondered is um
you know one i once heard a talk
actually it might be by my friend stefan
alexander up at brown
that basically only fermions are are
sort of fundamental in the sense that
you can make a boson out of out of two
fermions but you can't make a
fermion out of any number of bosons
right so
is there something special about about
fermions is there something more special
about them compared to bosons or are we
basically able to to kind of separate
their behaviors out and and treat them
accordingly
yeah so so i would i would not agree
with the idea that that that the only
fundamental particles are fermions
photons are bosons and they're pretty
fundamental and i'm saying i'm not
saying that he said that but i'm just
saying it was it was sort of a crazy
idea that we speculated about yeah so so
fermions are really really important
because it weren't for fermions this
would be a pretty dull world
so fermions are the thing that guarantee
the complexity of chemistry
if if electrons were bosons then all
atoms would just have
n electrons in the ground state and the
chemistry would be really boring so i
doubt that it would be possible
for us to exist
if it weren't for the fact that uh
electrons uh obey a poly exclusion
principle which is the thing that says
that they're there they're fermio as the
fact that those chemistry have one
uh
one electron in the same quantum state
right not the way you learned it in high
school but it's
exactly right a little update next
question comes from someone by the name
of hypergolic which i don't know
why someone would give their kid that
name i think it's a it's a nom de plume
uh he asks uh what's uh can we use
trapping of atoms to produce a quantum
hall effect can you pretty much
yeah right and the answer is yes we hope
so in our laboratory uh my colleague ian
spielman is the one who's doing the work
that is uh closely related to this
he has made
uh with uh with ultra cold atoms he has
made uh systems that exhibit a classical
hall effect
and then going to the quantum hall
effect just requires more work yeah okay
great
good um and the last thing is maybe
not politically correct given that
you're friends with jim gates but what
do you think about super symmetry and
string theory
well look
um neither
string theory nor supersymmetry and
you're right jim gates is is a good
friend and it it just breaks my heart
that we haven't seen super symmetric
particles because they ought to be there
yeah but so far
we're not seeing any supersymmetric
particles and with respect to string
theory it hasn't lived up to
its initial promise
but at the same time i think string
theory was an important and still is an
important feature of modern physics
because it gives us a glimmer
of how it might be
that we could unify quantum mechanics
and gravity it might not be the answer
but at least it it it gives us a feeling
that this might happen so maybe it's
going to be something else it's not
strings brains you know but but it seems
to me that that even though this may not
be the final answer uh
and the other thing is nobody's really
come up even you know with with new
predictions let alone even
old predictions that is not
we can't even use string theory to retro
date what uh right we already know well
actually
my friend come on rafa came on the
podcast about two years ago and he said
no string theory does make predictions
and retrodictions and it says that the
mass of the electron should be greater
than uh the planck mass and less than a
kilogram
that's great that only gives us you know
50 orders of magnitude uh but i i think
you're right not greater than the plank
mass blankness is immense
sorry sorry no 10 to the minus 12 flange
or something like that that's you're
right the plank mass is like a fit 10 of
my black brands or something okay so
bill i know you have to catch a plane um
i know you're so generous it's not a
plane but i actually have to have to
drive to the place where i'm where i'm
going but so if you'll indulge me i
haven't been on a plane since the
beginning of the pandemic wow i just
took one with some kids recently and it
was a real uh charade so uh thank your
stars that you haven't had to do that so
i wonder if you'll indulge me with a few
more minutes my final three thrilling
three questions that i ask all my
beloved guests you have a couple more
minutes bill let's do it okay great
[Music]
so the first one has to do with what is
called an ethical will which is sort of
an inheritance of wisdom of uh you know
benediction for the future not monetary
and as you know alfred nobel had a had
an ethical will but he also had a
monetary will the monetary will made the
prize but part of the prize was to do
the greatest benefit to mankind which
you have done with your colleagues and
and many other laureates for expanding
our horizons but i want to ask you your
personal
ethical will uh what piece of wisdom or
knowledge do you want to leave to the
millions of people around the world who
look up to you and so forth in terms of
wisdom or
or advice for their lives well
i don't know about the millions of
people i'm not sure millions of people
care what i think but at least for my
children
i can imagine some things that i would
like to leave to them i mean you know
um
probably the most important thing is be
kind to one another
do the right thing even if you don't
want to
even if it's hard
actually these two things are i think
already embodied in what is my favorite
passage of scripture from the hebrew
scriptures you probably know what i'm
going to say
micah
yep actually the lord require yes
to do justice
to love kindness
to walk humbly with your god
so that last part you know don't be too
full of yourself
another feature that's good advice but
now if if i was going to be a little bit
broader these people often ask me you
know what's your advice for me as a uh
as a
uh
a budding scientist well usually my
answer is
stay curious
keep that childlike curiosity
i think scientists are just children who
never grew out of that
that that childlike curiosity
don't stop learning that's a that's
maybe a corollary
of the uh of the state curious those are
those are the kinds of things that
uh there's one more thing
my father-in-law was a very wise man he
was an excellent woodworker
and he made beautiful pieces of
furniture
but sometimes
things didn't go quite the way he wanted
and his response was
a man on a galloping horse would never
notice the difference
and i think that if you take this as a
as a mantra in your life you can save
yourself an awful lot of worry
something i mean you know it's it's it's
another version of the perfect is the
enemy of the good
that's right
that that we have to understand when
things are good enough and you move on
yeah as i think uh voltaire around the
french revolutionary times we talked
about earlier sudden you're my now my
second guest in 200 interviews who's
quoted from micah for that very same uh
question that i asked and this is to
carl sagan's widow
uh andrewian when she was on the show
but as you know carl was a very very
prominent atheist and so is anne so she
left off the walk humbly she said walk
humbly and then she just ended the quote
and i said you know what you left off
and she said yes i do i still think it's
brilliant and that gave her so much
credit as an atheist to realize that
there is wisdom in these ancient
traditions
absolutely and uh look i i know an
atheist who has a favorite hymn
so
you know i think you're gonna feel
careful about about uh yeah exactly okay
well we looked that was looking forward
you know hopefully when you hit the
biblical age of 120 and beyond like
moses did uh the next one goes a billion
years into the future and i'm going to
ask you to look into your crystal ball
and i want to ask you um you know
relative to the namesake of the arthur c
clarke center which i uh you know i'm
the associate director of here in san
diego um and his movie uh 2001 a space
odyssey where the these primates in
africa and they come upon this black
ominous monolith and then it appears on
the moon and i'm not really sure what it
is maybe it's a maybe it's a warning
maybe it's a time capsule i like to
think of it as kind of like
a time capsule meant to brag and show
the swagger of humanity and so to that
end i want to ask you what you would put
on it you'd tattoo on it like your
colleagues or engrave into it like this
sketch scratchings on a on a platinum
rod or whatever that we spoke about but
i want to ask you looking forward into
the future
what would you put on a billion year
lasting time capsule
yeah but you know it's it's it's it's uh
it's it's really hard to
to know i guess that um
so so we're not asking the question
about
passing along knowledge but just to know
this is just what what what piece of
human wisdom like richard feinman your
fellow laureate said the atomic
hypothesis is those is the sum in the
most uh content of information in the
fewest words
what would you brag about that we've
learned about you've learned about or
anything that humanity would brag about
to tell alien civilizations and
billionaires from now to brag a little
bit about yeah so so if it was like that
that i wanted to tell something that was
a piece of scientific knowledge it would
be
that
in fact
nature follows
regular discoverable
mathematically expressible laws
the fact that that's true is in some
sense absolutely astounding magical
people i mean i would say that the
understanding of the truth of that in a
sense is the content
of
the um the the scientific revolution so
maybe there's one other thing and that
is what i think is the content of the
scientific method people often have some
formal thing for the scientific method
is i think that's garbage yeah key thing
about the scientific method is
that truth is determined by
the way nature is
nature is the final arbiter
of scientific truth not thinking about
it and deciding this is
you know sounds good but
is this the way nature actually works i
think that is the substance of the
scientific method you observe and you
experiment and that's the thing that
determines whether you've got it right
yeah and then
you uh the i always note that there's
not just one scientific method which is
not very scientific if you have multiple
but you should come to the truth and you
should have consensus uh you shouldn't
maybe have uniformity as you know in the
uh old testament if if all the judges on
the court found the the uh the accused
party guilty he or she was set free
because like somebody didn't do their
job defending
uh the the uh the other side uh quite
adequately okay we're gonna go one more
question for you and this is uh this is
arthur c clarke as you know had many
laws a very famous one that you at nist
embody which is any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic he had another one that i
drop on my department chair from time to
time which is for every expert there's
an equal and opposite expert i like that
one but last one is the third law says
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture a little
way past them into the impossible and
that is the origin of the name of this
podcast and i want to ask you bill kind
of advice to your uh former self as a
young person a 20 year old a 30 year old
i've asked nobel laureates like your uh
your your friend uh barry barish he told
me he had the imposter syndrome when he
collected his nobel prize i guess you
have to sign this little document that
says you got your prize a binder and he
saw this guy's name you know albert
einstein and he said i'm not worthy he
had the imposter syndrome i pointed out
einstein had people that he looked up to
like newton and and so forth but
uh what advice would you give to your
former self and secondly i'm curious
have you ever had the imposter
the second syndrome first yes absolutely
all the time whenever i go to a talk and
hear people talk about this and that
that i think my gosh i should have
learned that i should understand what
he's talking about oh my gosh i'm gonna
have to go back and learn that you know
i'm i'm just not in the game
that happens to me
all the time
uh okay so now what what advice would i
give my
okay a couple of things
don't trust everything that people tell
you
like what and here
i'm thinking especially of theorists
because they only know what they know
and
when
we're going to make progress by finding
out that they were wrong
and i think that there is a tendency of
thinking these guys are pretty smart
and you know they've they've figured
everything out outright and other people
have checked it and it's right
and not always yeah so part of that
story is that
uh
you know
now fast forward a little bit to when
i'm in my
late 30s or early 40s i forget when
um
probably about 40
we measure the temperature of the atoms
after laser cooling
and uh we get just what we expected
and then we measure some other stuff and
it's not working out right and so i go
to a theorist and i say you know we got
this these crazy results and it could be
if the temperature were a lot lower
than what the theory predicted it might
be some of these results would make
sense is there any way that that's
possible said absolutely not on general
principles i can show the temperatures
no way the temperature can be lower on
general principles i said okay fine
so a few months later we measured the
temperature and it was way lower
than what the theory said was the lowest
possible temperature in spite of the
fact that all these theorists
said that there was no way it could be
lower and that they had very general
arguments saying that it had to be
uh
this and so so okay so so don't pay that
much attention to what people tell you
they think is true
another thing is
we're taught when starting to do an
experiment we should really think it
through very carefully ask about how big
the signal noise is going to be what's
going to happen uh you know how we're
going to put it all together if we had
taken that seriously
when we started doing laser cooling
because we wanted to make a better
atomic clock we would have given up
right at the start because what the
theory told us we could do for the
lowest temperatures was not going to be
good enough to make a decent
uh atomic clock and we never would but
we just said
this looks like fun
making things cold with a laser just
sounds like fun because it ought to you
know you ought to be you shine laser on
something to make it hot
if we could
if we can make it cold by shining a
laser on it that's just really neat so
let's just do it
and it turned out that all the
roadblocks that we would have
taken seriously if we'd done things very
carefully just
disappeared
that that
it's easy or at least easier to figure
out all the reasons why things are going
to go wrong
than it is to figure how you're going to
fix it
when you're right in front of it
that that it's really hard to know what
to do with something until you're
holding it in your hand
and literally in that sense you went
into the impossible uh you had courage
it takes courage to go against uh you
know the advice of senior colleagues
perhaps you were saying you were in your
you know
early stage in your career it took a lot
of courage to go against it it reminds
me of the final
famous quote by arthur c clarke he said
when an elderly distinguished scientist
says something is possible he's most
likely or she's most likely right but
when they say it's impossible they're
most likely wrong
what do you think now is if if you were
a grad student and you're starting at
maryland or uc san diego or anywhere
what would you what would you do if you
if you and i said you can't do what
you've done you have to go completely
orthogonal to what you've done i'm just
curious bill what would you do
one of the things that i find absolutely
uh astoundingly interesting
is cell biology
it just seems like so much new stuff is
is happening so
so fast i mean look at these
mrna vaccines
that would have been impossible without
the things we've learned
about uh
uh about the genetic code uh in in the
last years and and look at how wonderful
those vaccines were much better than
anybody
dare dream and
great well bill i want to thank you so
much for sharing so much of your time
with us i hope someday we can do a part
two uh on the future of of uh where
we're going at the time keeping we we
had such a delight learning from you uh
you're kind of the type of professor
that i i wish i could have had growing
up and that i aspired to be and with
guests like you as inspirations i think
you do inspire more people than you can
possibly imagine so bill thank you so
much enjoy the rest of your day and
thanks for coming on the podcast with me
it's been a pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
my
[Music]